I've just finished chairing a long Cobra
meeting in which we've had online our
senior officials who are in Paris today
talking to Euro tunnel and to the French
authorities I'm pleased to say that
we've seen a much improved level of
cooperation and collaboration with
Eurotunnel over the last 48 hours with
trains being cancelled where appropriate
and in some cases trains being reversed
back into [ __ ] l where there was a
danger of illegal migrants being on
board from this evening UK border force
and French police will have a presence
in the eurotunnel control room at [ __ ] l
and that will greatly enhance the
practical collaborative working at the
site I also understand this evening that
the company has accepted our offer of
additional guards and we expect up to a
hundred additional guards to be deployed
into the terminal area the fencing work
is proceeding on schedule and we expect
that to further enhance security
meanwhile on this side of the channel we
are in the final stages of procuring
some additional facilities to support
the op stack Laurie holding operations
so that when it is switched on again
later this week the disruption on the
motorways will be less because we'll be
able to hold some of the freight
vehicles on off highway science finally
I just say that we are working very
closely with the French authorities on
putting together a joint plan to support
returns to country of origin by illegal
migrants seeking to enter the UK and
those who are in the Calais area in
France and Britain are determined to
work together to lead the campaign in
Europe for a more robust approach by the
European Union to ensuring that we get
returns of migrants to their countries
of origin why has the government not yet
got a grip on this crisis and do you
think it's appropriate the David Cameron
to be on holiday right now I think we
have got a grip on the crisis we saw a
peak last week since when the number of
illegal migrants has tailed off we've
taken a number of
in collaboration with the French
authorities and Eurotunnel which are
already having effect and over the next
day or two I would expect to have an
even greater effect border Force
personnel in the control room more
fencing in place additional guards hired
all of those things will slow down the
flow and we will deal with this problem